the Joe Rogan experience a little a
little scary a little new a Santa Fe
that's rotates from tape Fletcher's from
there co-owner of caveman coffee simply
delicious and really pumps you up well
played thank you these no I've never had
one its caveman nitro how susceptible
are you to caffeine no I mean 270
milligrams and that mother fall that's
what versus how much in a cup of coffee
a large Starbucks I think is like that
much I got venti Starbucks yeah did we
how many times we've gone over this and
I can never remember the numbers I want
to say that a venti Starbucks is like
250 or 240 and that's a 270 it's a touch
mol touch more really need it see we're
scared I'm drinking I thought you were
kind of giving me the vibe of like look
I don't have too many you know no no I'm
done I just got a new shipment no that's
not what I was giving the vibe I just
always tell people because I I've given
it to people and then like an hour into
the show they're like dude I'm on crack
I guess I'll call you later be like I
ran home I ran back to West Hollywood
okay so a venti why was I wrong
415 milligrams at all yeah this is a
tall Wow did they jack up the caffeine
is it always high come on
was it really always this high I feel
like you're looking up maybe the numbers
have changed dude I thought the old
number for like a cup of coffee for a
diner was 40 it's an amazing like 40
milligrams I always think about like
caffeine just a drug yeah so this is
just these guys just deal a drug Oh
delicious bean fell but it but it's also
addictive you know like once you're in
you're in
you can't not drink last person who
would like to deny all of his addictions
I can't follow with you on this I think
it's a lovely couple you don't think
that you could could you wake up and not
have one why would I do that why why
just just show everybody like why cans
like what people always like pots not
addictive I'm like have you tried not
smoking it for a week I could any time
the average caffeine content of a 8
ounce brewed cup of coffee is 95
milligrams so yeah so Starbucks is way
more yeah they're so an average of the
laws not a lot more
I would have guessed that was way high I
thought I for some reason thought in my
head like a cup of coffee from a diner
you know what those reasonable small
cups of coffee yeah I remember that
being 40 but that makes sense because
like a real cup of coffees probably
double that size anyway like 90
but 464 so it's not as bad as a venti
it's more like a tall 460 goddamn I feel
like they jack that caffeine up we're
will people some people get super
conditioned to it like Tate my friend
Tate the owner of the company he could
drink five of those things just
here and throwing back yeah he's also a
gorilla he's a big giant dude that's a
big factor fat how much body weight yeah
he's moving around a lot of tissue yeah
probably to 40 I mean I have friends can
drink like that but they're just big
giant suits giant dude yeah well thank
you Justin I have a friend who's a legit
giant he's like seven feet tall you do
huge yeah and he can put down some
makers and coke that will you up
yeah I can't try to keep you can't try
to keep up yeah I have a couple friends
like that they're like let's grab
another one like dude I'm gonna die you
go to the Darklands
yeah oh my god I'll keep drinking but
like let me you have a glass of water
here you know dude you just
booze
[Applause]